but what about validation did you ever
feel like uh you needed validation from
your father
he found him my Dad loved me and he was
proud of me you know he used to stop
people on the street and I've I had
people stop me on the street when I was
much younger and go I Met Your Dad I'm
like yeah yeah I was crossing the street
and I read waiting in red light and he
said he just said hey do you know Andrew
McCarthy he's not my son and so like my
dad used to sort of weird you know if
they were the right demo he would stop
them you know and
which I found very sad in a certain way
I did that broke my heart before him I
was just that really made me sad I was
first humiliated by it and angered by it
when I was young and then it made me
very sad for him later but I mean I know
my dad was proud of me and you know all
that stuff but
in his way yeah you know it's weird
because I
sometimes people ask me this question
and then I'll go huh
and the question is do you think your
parents love you and they're so trying
to be in your life a little bit more
because you've had success because you
have because you have maybe a little
money because you have and so did you
ever have to deal with that where
there's like your father you say he
disappeared but then when you started
having the success he would see people
in the street he'd say that's my son he
was all this did you think okay but what
if I wasn't successful did that ever
haunt you like is he doing it because he
really well I think success
my public success young really harmed my
relationships and my family very much so
um I was not the star of the family
growing up you know what I mean my
brother I have three brothers two older
one younger and my oldest brother was
like smart and you know that and the
other one was The Jock and I was like
the sensitive kid or something but I was
not the star of the family you know and
when I became one in a public way at 21
22 years old that sort of blew up my
household
and or my you know my parents got
divorced around that time anyway so they
were going through their own thing but
it sort of blew up my relationship with
my brother my brothers uh because
they're still in their mid-20s trying to
figure out who they are and suddenly
their little brother is like some movie
star and you know what I mean that was I
think that was difficult for them to uh
navigate and so
I found the opposite with success in my
family and so it kind of made me because
of my temperament just sort of flee that
and go this isn't a safe place I'm I'm
you know what I'm a Loner a bit anyway
so I I kind of the combination of that
and with feeling slightly poached by
them made me uh just flee you know what
I've had a lot I had a lot of people
early on ask me for money and things
when I was young and family members do
tonight and you know invariably you give
it to them at the beginning Until you
realize that people whoever you give
money to hate you for it
because you're basically saying I'll do
for you what I see you can't do for
yourself and people hate you for that
and so everyone who I tried to help
financially and presented me for it so I
stopped you know doing that I I
still enable I still do it I'm much
better at it now but it angers me that I
do it my actual my business so why do
you do it
um because I don't want to feel guilty
when they die
uh-huh
that doesn't add up
[Laughter]
that math it's two and two is like five
I want to say that hey I really did
everything I could and I was really a
good brother or a good son or a good
whatever but it gets to a point where
it's like can't you cut it off and still
say you did that because you did that
for so long it's like when does it end
and you you came to a point where you
cut it off with your dad
um
I haven't had my father doesn't need
money but like someone in my family they
do and they but they don't they have
always sort of you know been the victim
they've always sort of like you know I
need this I can't do this they're
married they have it it doesn't make
sense but I keep helping out because I
do love them and I want them to be happy
I don't want them to be destitute and
maybe there's an ego thing maybe there's
maybe there's sort of like oh if I let
that happen and then all of a sudden oh
they can't then all of a sudden the town
where I grew up and all they're like oh
you you're
your family there you have money why
aren't you helping them maybe there's
that sort of like I care about what
other people think well of course
you know I give you money so I'm you
know I'm empowered I have power over you
now I don't want it I really don't I
don't want to have that power I just
want them to be happy and do whatever
they can to make ends meet and do the
things that I think are simple simple
steps into doing that because you know I
have friends that you know I know that
if I didn't have a job I would go get a
job if I didn't have money I would go
figure out how to make money these are
certain things that were ingrained in me
that I always knew and and it's easy to
save now when you're doing well but I
know that and a lot of people are like
that they're like hey I'll go I'll work
at McDonald's I'll work it wherever I'll
but maybe there's pride in whatever and
they don't want to do that for sure when
my dad was wanting money I always he
said I'd be proud of your dad if you're
a bad person in the checkout you know at
the supermarket but you know easy for me
to say yeah
that's true and it was that would have
been the truth but it wasn't he wasn't
being able to do that and I get that
yeah I get that I wouldn't want to be
bagging in the supermarket either hey
you're that guy from mannequin what are
you doing putting my groceries